MANDY WAITE: How popular is
Google App Engine for Java?
Most examples seem
to be written for
Google App Engine Python.
FRED SAUER: I hope that's
not the case as far
as the sample mismatch.
It is true that we launched
App Engine Python a year
before the Java runtime.
So in 2008, it was Python, and
then in 2009, we added the
Java runtime, and later
we added Go.
So there may be just a little
bit of bias still left in the
system, because we originally
set out to just have a Python.
But I think things are
fairly evened out.
If you go to the Google Cloud
Platform user on GitHub,
there's many samples there.
There's Java and
Python samples.
Documentation, there should be
samples in both languages.
I don't recall the exact kind
of popularity, but I thought
it was fairly even.
It may be a 60/40 split, or
something like that with some
percentage going to Go.
But you shouldn't feel like
Java's an underappreciated
language on App Engine.
That's definitely
not the case.
And if you look at the talks
at I/O, you'll then see our
focus on Java users and making
sure they have a just as good
experience as Python.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
That's excellent.
FRED SAUER: So, pick the
language that's good for you.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah,
definitely, yeah.
Absolutely.